welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chris
hogan ramsey personality number one
best-selling author
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions
about your life and your money open
phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five chris
before we jump to the phones i want to
just take a minute and say thank you to
our good friends pastor craig and amy
grochelle
at life church and the whole team at
life church in oklahoma city
we were there yesterday all day doing
doing uh pre-taping some things and then
last night did our
reset event from oklahoma city last
night
craig spoke and you and rachel and i
and um about 240 000 people
were registered to watch it it was the
number two thing
on youtube in the world the only thing
ahead of
us uh on youtube last night was the
impeachment hearings
and so you've got like one negative
thing going on and one positive one
positive that's right
where they're helping people and um the
all of the speakers uh were on their a
game the delivery was incredible craig's
talk was
off the chain and uh the team behind the
scenes
our team and the technical team and the
uh
guys at life church to be able to pull
something like that off for 200 000 plus
streams going through facebook youtube
anything else out there
uh it was it was incredible it really
was and
you know it's it in this time right now
that we have going on
people need hope they need a plan that
actually works
and i was just excited to be a part of
it and like you said that church
and the whole entire team there is
absolutely
just they have the heart to serve and so
it was just a great opportunity to be
there with them and to help people
well they're not only one of the largest
churches in america but
they if not the largest church in
america but their technical skill
is world-class i mean this is the these
are the folks that put out the u-version
bible app that has a half a billion
people around the world using it with a
bee
and um you know i mean that's pretty
crazy
and uh and on top of all of that talent
and size and scale
there is not an icky person in the
building no i've known craig
fresh craig for 20 plus years since he
was doing the thing out of his garage
and it has just grown leaps and bounds
and he has personally grown
through that time and uh just
incredibly humble loving
yeah serving people yeah that's the word
that i kept thinking as he was
hanging out just talking to us just his
heart uh his heart is
to serve people and the whole team's
that way the whole team everyone
now not to mention they've got like a
command central i walk by that thing
and i was like is this this looks like a
major news station yeah
i was like let me go in there and turn
some knobs and i didn't because i don't
know what i'm doing
fox fox business wishes they had a setup
like that it's incredible
so this event was obviously a blast i
was there i had a chance to be a part of
it
can people watch this dave after the
fact
yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna we
were running it live of course last
night and i think the guys are posting
it today
where you can go back reset 20 21 yeah
and it's time to get a reset it's time
to get a fresh start it's time
after 2020 to put that in your rear view
mirror and that was our messages and
showing you how to do that from each of
our perspectives
and from the uh actual thing uh you know
the actual delivery of the content the
but the tactical things to go take away
and do
and of course we're running a special on
ramsey plus a bundle associated with it
that was incredible
and uh thousands and thousands and
thousands of people bought that last
night
yeah and uh and i wanna tell you i'm
gonna i'm gonna put out a tease here and
trust me it will not let you down
dave's take on the three little pigs
that's all i'm gonna tell you
but i want you to go watch this and
listen to it because it is
absolutely hilarious but it's on point
dave's take on the three little pigs
reset 2020 you need to go watch it
and then i want you to tweet me or post
on my instagram and tell me what you
thought because
i loved that story
i really did our modified version
you need to you need to you need to
watch it though it is and it's so
applicable right now and this end up
with more children's books around here
than anything
you know we just bring out all the bring
out all the uh
the old-time hits from the fairy tales
or whatever but
seriously guys thank you guys all of you
that turned out hundreds of thousands of
you watching that last night it'll be
by the end of the week it'll be well
over a million folks have viewed that
and it's just it was an incredible thing
to be part of
and to be able to put out there at a
time when folks need
something to focus on that is not
crap out of washington or not crap
out of uh you know public shaming for
this or that
yeah and of course there's always you
know one or two negative ninis out there
but they're
that's just part of it i mean if you do
anything of scale you could expect the
morons to show up that's part of
who shows up so oh yeah if you get out
of bed
and leave your house you're going to
have somebody didn't like that oh yeah
they didn't like the way you walked down
your front door
because you slammed your door dave
ramsey one way to avoid criticism say
nothing do nothing and be nothing these
are not options for us at ramsey no
so uh we'll bring the criticism's part
of the uh it's table stakes it's part of
the uh
uh permission uh as part of the uh
part of the sign up fee to be me and i
signed up
so bring it bring it in the meantime
hundreds of thousands now well over a
million people are getting
help for free yeah and somebody forgot a
way to [ __ ] about that okay
so um really unbelievable but
so it was an incredible incredible thing
and i just i
mean i have gotten to do a lot of
major events and arenas and other things
that we have put on or i have spoken at
uh large things you know 10 20 000
people in live in an audience that kind
of a thing over the years and those are
it's a it's a it's an experience to do
that kind of a thing
but this was a you know a fairly small
audience um
uh you know it's not a huge auditorium
number one number two
with socially distancing and the other
things that we abided by the local
government's
guidelines and everything um and
you know but but uh the number of the
size of this online audience for this
thing was
it was it was earth changing yeah it was
pretty amazing so thank you guys all of
you that tuned in we appreciate it
if you haven't tuned in uh like i said
we're gonna post it and you'll be able
to jump on daveramsey.com and figure out
a way to watch it somewhere
i don't even know how that works right
now daveramsey.com
hogan's shopping story just to
hear hogan talk about him grocery
shopping and the
view the visual of that that goes into
your head that will never leave
it's worth watching just for that but uh
the content was all
awesome and again you'll leave it'll be
worth the uh
hour and a half hour and 45 minutes it
takes you to watch and uh
it'll be worth your time and again
didn't doesn't cost you a thing so
daveramsey.com
reset and we want you guys to reset we
want you to win
we want you to make choices where you're
not vulnerable
to everything that is going on out there
there's a sections of this nation
portions of the spaces out there that
have completely
lost their freaking minds and the only
way you can insulate yourself from
the wackiness is to uh is to
follow god's principles of handling
money and when you do
you put yourself in a position then be
insulated that's right and that's what
we're teaching you to do
the good times and bad times these same
principles
will cause you to prosper this is the
dave ramsey show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high
quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five david
is in washington d.c hi david welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi gentlemen thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i have a question my wife and i have
a
529 plan for our son in the state of
virginia
and he's got one and a half years left
until leaving for college
we think it's pretty much fully funded
so we're only putting small amounts into
it now
but we're concerned that maybe our
distributions are a little too
aggressive now so we've got like 78
in stocks 18 in bonds 4 in cash
and we wanted to just kind of know
should we back off of that a little
either now or next year or as we head
into college
how much is in there um
we have in there right now
a hundred sixty-five thousand okay well
done
congratulations that's fabulous that is
great
very fortunate uh and and when you say
stocks bonds and cash you're talking
about you've got
it's a mutual fund selection you're not
in individual stocks or bonds
that's correct we have uh mutual funds
through american funds yeah okay yes
well here's the thing
bonds have an inverse relationship
as you probably know david to the
interest rate market
so as interest rates go down
bonds prices go up interest rates have
been
unbelievably low for an unbelievably
long period of time
there's not a lot of places they're
going to go but up
in terms of major moves in interest
rates in the next five years okay
while your kids in school and so
while bonds are typically pitched if you
read the standard financial planning
writing people pitch bonds as a
stabilizer in a portfolio
in an extended low interest rate
environment my
personal conviction is that they are a
destabilizer because i think as interest
rates tick up those bond prices are
going to go
down you're going to lose your butt on
that part of the portfolio
uh and so it's while it's supposed to be
more safe
than the than the stocks i don't think
it is in this current world
personally so you can do what you want
to do but you called us so
that that's an opinion it worked
probably worth what you paid for it i
don't
consequently i don't own any bonds right
now
matter of fact i've never really used
bonds much in my investing at all
unless they're in a balanced fund or
something like that but so
then the question just becomes do you
want to be in cash or do you want to be
in uh growth stock type mutual funds
uh for the next three and a half four
and a half years because the
bulk a piece of that money is not going
to come out for five for four years
right that's right
correct so i'm probably gonna stay
uh depending on how worried you are
about the stock market
uh i'm gonna the less worried you are
i'm gonna stay heavy heavy heavy in in
the
in the in the uh growth stock mutual
funds and and a little bit of cash
and the more worried you are the more i
would be about cash but
i don't think it's unsophisticated as a
matter of fact
it's just a different way of thinking
it's a different critical thinking set
to avoid bonds number one and to number
two to say
ah the risk represented by the market is
not so substantial
on stocks that it's going to drive me
crazy well and the mindset dave i think
this year has or
this past year i keep to keep going
backwards here uh the past year has
shown us as we looked at what happened
to the stock market in march
and then how it rebounded and came back
in october yeah you know for us to make
sure that we remember it's the
long-range view
right and and i think that is that i'm
going to keep beating that drum of
riding the roller coaster long-range
view look at what's going on don't
listen to what people are saying watch
what's happening
yeah um i mean on the short term the
only thing that disturbs me for the
stock market's sake
more than anything else is just the
level of political unrest oh i agree
that's a short term um i mean if you
believe that the political unrest is
going to lead to
the uh the nation unraveling then you'd
get out of the stock market completely i
don't believe that
uh but uh the stock market does not like
an unpredictable world
it likes a predictable world even if
it's a liberal world or a conservative
world right
a democrat or a republican it just just
let me know out what it is
and i can predict it and when when
things aren't predictable so if a war
springs up across the world
geopolitical it doesn't like that this
crap going on in washington
on both sides of the aisle right is
astronomically crazy when the cities
were burning last summer
right without getting into reasons or
whether agreement or anything like that
the stock market doesn't like it right
well it's a living breathing thing as
you've told
people for years and because it's living
and breathing it's got feelings
and so the stock market has feelings and
so imagine if too much unrest or too
much
this or that happens there is going to
be a reflection at some point yeah
it's when people are worried it shows up
right that's really what it comes down
to
because it depends depending on what
they're worried about so anyway all that
to say david i
personally if you if it was my kid i
would be heavy in stocks i'd be light to
none in bonds
and to the extent you're worried i would
crank up my percentage in cash
uh to the extent you're worried about
the next two years
of volatility but if the thing goes down
10 percent that would be almost
that'd be one of the biggest drops in 12
months in the history of the stock
market
if it went down 10 and that would be 16
000 doesn't keep your kid from going to
school no
so you're not really playing with huge
huge risk you're not gonna have a
situation where you lose
50 of your money that has occurred only
two times in the entire history of the
stock market
and i do not see that item on the
horizon it could be there but i don't
see it well and let's talk real quick
here about obviously with student
education and going to college
you've got 165 000 that you put away you
know as you start to look in state
at 10 000 a year you've covered out of
state tuition is 22 000 a year
and private tuition is around 36 000 so
you know you look at the dollar amount
that you all have set aside david you
all have done a fantastic job
of being prepared now do finish the job
i guess is what i'd say
help your young person make a smart
decision and don't pick a school based
on a sports team
and don't pick something based on a
mascot let's pick ones pick something
that is fiscally responsible
that you can pay cash for there you go
danielle is with us in indianapolis hi
danielle how are you
hi mr ramsay and mr hogan how are you
guys great how can we help
good um so my fiance and i have been
listening to your show
for a month or two now and we'd like
your advice on a student loan repayment
decision
um so we're getting married this may
after i graduate from college
and congratulations graduating debt free
thank you
so i'll be graduating debt free is i've
already paid off around 8 000
in federal student loans from fellowship
funds that i've been awarded
during the past two years and my fiance
will graduate college later in december
of this year
and has around nine thousand dollars of
federal unsubsidized student loan debt
and about ten thousand of private debt
owed to his parents
i would like to pay off his federal
student loan debt now
so that it wouldn't accrue any more
interest before he graduates
and to just get it off of our shoulders
as we prepare for marriage
but he wants to wait until after he
graduates in december to pay the loan
um so what do you guys think that we
should do danielle davis twitching over
here
uh i felt that i've been around here for
15 years i i
love that you have been intentional and
that you're going to graduate debt-free
this is just impressive
uh did you pay for it or did your
parents pay for it
i paid for it um i'm i've received a
fellowship
of five thousand dollars for the past
two years so that has helped me to pay
for it well i'm proud of you
and and i would say this and i'm dave's
going to dive all over this
love that you've joined and you're
listening to this love that you guys
at a young age are talking about this
but i'm going to tell you something you
know first and foremost
i wouldn't be doing anything for his
debt until you guys are actually married
uh until he says i do and you do and we
do
then you can start to have a plan
together but prior to that you need to
stay focused on what it is you're doing
he needs to come up with a plan to try
to attack that before you get married
yeah after marriage we can do a lot of
stuff
okay so i mean say that we wait until
we get married in may um yeah well you
do that either way but you said in may
then do you pay it off or do you wait
till december
it doesn't matter if you've got the
money that's fine after marriage to
knock it out the primary concern of god
is is that he finishes with no
additional debt
it'd be a shame to pay it off and then
not have the cash
for him to finish that last semester in
the fall yep so if you've got that set
up and you guys want to go ahead and
start attacking it there's not a wrong
answer you're
both of these are smart choices it's a
smart or be smart
so but all of it comes after may
this is the dave ramsey show
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same talking financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget friendly option and the original
health cost sharing ministry for
christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if there's one thing we
learned from last year about investing
you cannot invest alone
you absolutely need someone in your life
who knows the market better than you and
helps you make smart decisions teaches
you
as you're responding to all this crazy
out there listen i love diy do it
yourself but i don't pull my own teeth
i don't even work on my own cars anymore
do-it-yourself investors
do the same thing you pull your own
teeth you'll make a mistake
you lack the experience to make good
investing decisions you invest in the
wrong things
you get caught up in trends you read
some stupid article on the internet and
there's a lot of stupid articles on the
internet
you make rookie mistakes and then a year
like 2020 comes along
and uh all your mistakes are revealed
as warren buffett says you can tell he
was skinny dipping when the tide goes
out you see the mistakes
it's a bad idea it is and so trust me
you don't need all of this last year uh
let last year stay in the past say never
again let your retirement be at the
mercy of a dumpster fire
text to the word invest get with one of
our smartvestor pros text
invest two three three seven eight nine
text invest two thirty three
seven eighty nine paul is with us in
grand rapids michigan hey paul welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris uh first i'd like to
say i really enjoyed
your life presentation last night oh
thank you and
i want to give you a little background
about myself um i'm an everyday
millionaire
my wife and i should say way to go yeah
we uh just kind of live a conservative
life
we don't want the best we're content
with what we have we drive
two small cars when we could afford a
big suv we're just we're just content
people
so we've been able to save and invest
good
and my question my question is right now
i'm i've retired
a year ago and i've got money in a
traditional iras
and then the roth iras to the tune of
about
five hundred thousand dollars for each
one
now i know the rmd is coming up when i'm
71 right now i'm 65.
but it makes sense to convert
the traditional to some roth or just
stay with what i have well obviously as
you convert it
do you have extra cash to convert it and
pay the taxes with
uh yeah i probably have four hundred
thousand dollars on top of what i have
here
okay and just miscellaneous cash so
obviously if you
if you roll 500 into a roth it's all
becomes taxable
and so you're going to create yeah
you're going to create taxes of 100
150 something like that out of that and
um if you want to do that and then
that that does away with your rmd issue
because my guess is part of what's
bothering you is you don't need any of
this money you want to let it roll
well basically i'm hoping to pass it on
to my children
and it might be uh less messy to do that
if it's a raw
agreed agreed it just hurts it just
hurts to think about the taxes on that
yeah but the the math will work out this
way
you will recoup at about the 10-year
mark
and so uh if you're not that 500 that's
in the traditional
if we say all right today we roll it 10
years from today you'll be glad you did
prior to that you won't be
you would have been rather you'd have
been better off to have left it in there
and pay the taxes on the growth the
continued growth
and pay taxes on whatever you have to
draw down on rmd
as you pull it out and so that um
you know that if your guys if you guys
are in good health
i'm probably rolling it but uh because
basically that extra tax money you pay
has the same exact effect
mathematically is having invested that
if you don't reduce the 500 by the tax
and you allow the whole 500 to stay
right in the roth it has the same effect
of putting another 150 into a roth
or whatever your tax bill is
have you calculated the tax bill
uh well not really but i think we're
probably in the in the 20 25
range okay so then 100 100 then is what
we're talking about
and you know what could happen is you
might it might cause bracket creep if
you do it all in one year you may want
to straddle a calendar year
may want to do something this year some
in 22 to key you know get with your tax
guy
and run a tax person and run some
calculations on when you move it but
overall if you guys are healthy i'm
moving it yeah
no that's good and paul i'm going to
tell you this i love the fact that you
have this legacy mindset and you want to
pass some on to your kids
but i want you and your wife to enjoy it
like i want you guys to go do some stuff
take some trips get you an rv right you
know i mean i want you to start to live
and enjoy this
because you all have been very
intentional you've worked very hard
to reach everyday millionaire status uh
congratulations
your hard work and diligence and
consistency
paid off yeah well done very very well
done it sounds like with the house
depending on what the house is
probably two million dollar network oh
easy yeah so well done
that's pretty incredible and uh you know
it's not your nature to be frivolous
with money that's not what chris is
suggesting
uh but you did work you know you did
live like no one else so now you should
live
and give like no one else and the gift
portion is part of your
legacy that you're planting with the
kids and all of that but i don't want
you to
uh you know eat stale tuna fish and day
old bread so the kids get four dollars
more yeah
no i to me i think that's ridiculous uh
so it's important but yeah
definitely talk to a tax professional uh
and dave the thought of being able to
straddle it over the year and spread it
out that's very wise
uh as well as your investment
professionals so you can know exactly
where you are the timing
and what to do and also real quick as we
talk so much about smartvestor pros you
all
i really and truly want you to make sure
you get connected with one today
if you're not in these times with all
the stuff that's going on
it is imperative that you have someone
that you can reach out to
to just have a conversation about their
thoughts on what's going on or what
could happen
you don't have to speculate you don't
have to listen to the talking heads on
on on tv news you can talk to a pro
and i really want you to know they're
not going to judge you they're there to
help you so definitely reach out go to
daveramsey.com
get connected to a smartvestor pro there
you go open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five abigail
is with us in austin texas hey abigail
how are you
hi dave i'm great thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
so i own three rental properties
and one of them i own with my ex-husband
i own 75
he owns 25 percent joyful and
well he and i we actually we get along
very well he's a realtor i'm a realtor
we see eye to eye so there's no
disharmony around the management of the
property
so so the deal is this uh because i'm
interested to know what you would do in
this situation
given that interest rates are so low i
inquired with my mortgage banker about
refinancing
so right now it's at four and a half
percent and she told me we could get
down to 2.625
but at that time my ex-husband said you
know do you want to buy me out
because he you know he's like i don't
want to refinance and extend the loan
whatever
so she did let me know that we could
roll it all
in together the problem is that
uh so the house is the value is
somewhere around 400 to 425
and so my share would be around 100 and
when i
just run the numbers um
it looks like i would negative cash flow
by a couple
thousand dollars per year if i took on
that additional
debt load and so um
and so you know i just wanted to get
your your opinion about what you would
do in the circumstance my ex-husband is
fine to continue
as is you know not refinancing
um so what is the the current
mortgage is 200
the the balance you mean you know your
current balance today
is what 120. 120
okay all right
all right i'm coming up on the clock
hang on we come back from this break
we'll talk this through with you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personalities my
co-host today we're talking with abigail
in austin texas
all right abigail let me go back and
make sure i got my numbers right
because my head's spinning a little bit
here you got a rental property you own
with your ex it's worth 400
you owe 120. you own 75 he owns 25
you're talking about uh refinancing from
a an interest rate in the high fours to
an interest rate down in the twos which
makes a lot of sense he doesn't want to
do that
but in it while it all came up he said
hey just buy me out
is that what you told me that's that's
exactly correct
and you told me that if you were to
refinance and buy him out
that um that you would be negative cash
flowing per
year okay well that's where i got lost
because let's see here you've got a 280
000 equity but you should not be buying
him out on the 280 000 you should buy
them out based on
two based on 400 minus about 40 for
expenses
and so you've got about a 240 000 equity
is that sound about right
um uh i got lost there
okay okay if you're buying a partner out
on a piece of real estate you don't do
it at retail
you do it at what it would be net in a
sale
and so if you sell a 400 000 piece of
property you guys are real estate agents
so you wouldn't might not have the
commissions
but the commissions you would have made
if you paid out a commission
and you had other miscellaneous expenses
and you negotiated a little bit
uh the 400 would be discounted by about
10
at least you wouldn't net and you might
net 90
of the gross amount right
okay and so that'd be forty thousand off
and you've got a 280 thousand dollar
equity so it's a 240 000
equity so his portion is only worth
about 60.
okay see how i did i mean that's that's
fair that's not ripping him off that's
not ripping you off
nobody's getting a deal here but uh you
know i have the same thing set up in my
estate plan if
uh because i've got a bunch of real
estate if one of the kids wants to buy
out
one of the other kids on a piece of
property so they don't have to own it
together
uh they do it at an eighty percent ratio
hmm because because it's not fair to do
it at full appraisal it's not
that that's craziness because that's not
the way they because they can't get that
they can't get full appraisal net net
net so anyway
60 and 120 is only 180
of a mortgage on 400 i do not understand
why that property is not cash flowing
okay well uh in that i mean
in that scenario i mean that changes
things if i i was thinking that i would
be
adding 100 000 to the
balance well there's no way it's a
hundred thousand this is 280
at the most
so just so so you're saying this is
because you have to
there's that it's the equity versus uh
the balance in other words yeah you're
buying out people
because it is the equity because the
only thing if you guys sell it
you get 75 of the equity he gets 25 of
the equity after expenses agreed
right yep and so his 25 is only worth 25
of the equity after expenses
that's what his position's worth your
positions were 75
of that that's you know if you if you
were in a court for instance and this
was a
negative breakup that's how the judge
would make you calculate it
because that's a that's the proper way
of doing this because if you guys put it
on the market and sell it that's what
you're going to net
he's going to net about 60. right okay
and so anyway at at at 100
and 120 000 mortgage today plus 60 or
plus even 80 which is not which is too
much
that's only 200 000 mortgage on a 400
000 property that should cash flow
okay um i don't know
unless this property is is the rental
market in this particular neighborhood
sucking no no no no
no i mean i'm getting right now i mean
it definitely cash flows right now i'm
getting
the it's actually two houses on one lot
and combined at
24.50 total rent that's not much on the
400 000
value um
well actually you're correct but we've
uh we've had very long-term tenants
and so to the point that you're
discounted your your rental by
uh i mean that thing ought to be making
one percent a month anyway you ought to
be making four grand on that
well actually no
and maybe you need to sell this property
you may need to sell this property
because your cash on cash return
or your internal rate of return on this
after you're doing noi and everything
as deeply as you've got this thing
discounted this is not a good property
i wouldn't i wouldn't hold that yeah and
abigail i'm going to tell you pure
not even based on numbers based on life
based on on simplifying your life and
putting you in the driver's seat
is i'm not gonna own a property with an
ex i'm not
and so you know i'm gonna either buy out
as dave was talking about
i'm gonna sell this thing uh just real
simple
there's no reason for you to have to
continue to go around and around and i
know
things are going well right now but you
and i both know
it's just going to take a hiccup it's
just going to take something for old
stuff to come back
clean your life out get this thing get
it gone and then you can go buy a home
the right way well there's
like three or four different things
going on here there's that
and that's a reason to get rid of it
we've got to get the calculation if
you're going to do the buyout
down to what it should be and not
overpay for the buyout
and so at least a 10 percent discount on
your gross
reducing your your equity by 40 grand
and then the uh the third problem is
discovered late in the phone call and
that is is that you guys are not making
very good money on this
property if you have four hundred
thousand dollars invested in a piece of
property
you need to be grossing 3 500 to 4 000 a
month on that
uh in most markets and austin texas is
not a bad market
and so you ought to be making somewhere
in that
uh approaching one percent a month on it
in top line
in order to have justified tying up that
much money
into something so the and i i listen i
got a lot of property if i have a
long-term renter
i don't always get full market right but
i'm not running at
percent of market ever well i think the
thing she was trying to wrap her head
around is dave you just gave her a phd
in real estate and she's a realtor
uh and me too just looking at this and
talking about how to discount it before
you sell it
and so you know that's not something
everybody knows uh
being aware of because you're right you
are going to have fees you are going to
have expenses
so you can't just do a straight 25 or
whatever it is
in someone else's position i mean that
would be the deal of the year for him
it would be a great deal all right zach
is with us zach's in kalamazoo hi zach
how are you
i'm great hi dave and chris uh thank you
for taking my call uh so my wife and i
are big fans we had a great date night
with reset last night so thank you for
that
thank you so i'll get i'll get right to
it so i have
three kids and need help figuring out
how to allocate
money into efas for each of them based
on age
and that so my kids are six
and then i have two uh twins at the age
of two
and then i have one more on the way in
march
thank you
well um you know what i would do is just
sit down with your smart investor pro
with a financial calculator
and you can decide you're talking about
how much money to put in based on their
age right
yeah because we've got next to nothing
started for anybody and so we've got the
six-year-old and obviously he's closest
and so we're wondering like do we
do we throw a little more in his bucket
and then yes you would
you would and that's fair it's not
unfair equal is not fair fair is not
equal
so uh what what is correct is
to sit down i mean the technical way to
do it and i'm enough of a nerd i would
actually do this
i mean i would just sit down and say all
right we're looking at x for college
um and let's just make up a number i
want a hundred thousand dollars in this
account
there's probably not enough okay but i
want a hundred thousand dollars in each
of their accounts
what have i got to put in for a
six-year-old to do that what have i got
to put in for a four-year-old to do that
and what have i got to put in for a zero
to do that
uh a zero old and um so because you
can't start that account until they're
born and you get a social security
number anyway but
you could sit down and calculate that
and you know if you wanted to like say
per
month and then and then if it comes out
and the total of those numbers
is more than you're ready to do on your
baby step five
it still gives you a ratio if the
six-year-olds
double the the zero double the new baby
then whatever you put in for the new
baby double it for the six-year-old
right or whatever you put in for the
six-year-old take half of that and put
it into the baby
so you'll get a ratio of uh even if you
don't fully fund today which is fine to
not today you got young enough you'll
catch up later
you know if you if you if i just want
you on baby step five to start doing
something
yes and that's gonna give you peace of
mind
and clarity for the future amen and amen
good job zach
well done sir congratulations this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story live from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the dave ramsey show where
debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality is my
co-host today open phones at
[Music]
825-5225
is with us in erie pennsylvania hi
stevie welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you how can we help
well my question is regarding choosing a
financial partner
looking towards marriage
okay so currently i'm in
a serious relationship you know we're
both pursuing a longer goal
but i've noticed some things that are
red flags i would say
and i'm not sure if i'm being over
critical in it or just
being attentive to the situation so this
individual
for instance there are a couple examples
i can give one of them
is if we were to both go out to a
restaurant this person's been
unemployed for the past nine months you
know they will order the most expensive
item on the menu every single time
when they are being paid for but when
it's my turn to pay you know it's
i always pick the cheapest keeping in
mind the fact that we're both students
and i'm also working currently
the second example would be he just
graduated
and he took two months to get persuaded
into looking for jobs seriously
and now that he's found one within three
days he's already considering quitting
me it's just being a bit of a red flag
stevie how long have you all been
together
uh about eight months how old are you
guys
i'm sorry what was that how old are you
guys i am 27
and he is about to be 26. okay
see i'm going to tell you something i
think i don't i think whenever you have
those red flags and and
these things that you're you're talking
about and looking at these are things
that i think there are probably more
uh that you could allude to if we really
pressed and talked
i'm gonna tell you you're probably
dealing with someone that's not
motivated
um and this to me could sound like it
could end up being a project for you
later in life on many other fronts
i i i would move on i really and truly
would
uh because you want someone that that's
that's that's equal with you that wants
to
chase and conquer and work together as a
team
right now in the row boat you're the
person that's rowing and he's relaxing
and and i don't think that that's the
kind of life you want long term for you
and your and your own legacy
yeah and also it's a concern too when a
lot of people hear my major
they're like oh you're gonna make money
but they don't realize the investment
that's gone into it
and the work that's gone behind like
funding my own education
yeah well you're a driven person you're
motivated
you've got things that you want to
accomplish and i i don't think there's
anything
with allowing this individual to be a
good friend uh
but i i would move on if i were you i
think you've seen enough red flags to
let you know
something's not quite right here
you know sometimes sometimes a way to uh
it's a little tough for us in a
two-minute radio call to
dictate the next decade of your future
with a relationship situation but
uh a couple things pop into my mind just
hearing your story and listening to you
uh there's no question you're a very
goal-oriented person you have a lot of
initiative and a lot of drive
and so you're and you're self-aware
enough to know i could be overly
concerned about this i could be a little
bit legalistic about it
and that's good to worry about that a
little bit to to be
you know to on your part you don't be
you don't be a jerk on every little
detail right
but the things that you the second thing
that you mentioned
um unemployed for nine months
finally does get a job uh and then
immediately hates the job and wants to
quit
uh you know just that one sounds a lot
more serious than just
the the price of your entree um
you know and the the lack of manners
around ordering the expensive thing when
you're not paying
manners i mean if you if if we told
somebody not to get married based on
manners
sharon wouldn't ever marry me i didn't
have any manners still don't have a lot
but she's taught me a few
um but the uh um i finally figured out
which
fork and all that stuff but the uh
but uh so one two two things pop into my
head that i always
think of when i'm in situations like
yours
um three things i had another one pop
into my head
one is a buddy of mine says when there's
something bothering you down inside
when your spirit is disturbed there's a
reason
and your spirit's disturbed and that's
why you called
and you're just looking for someone to
confirm to you that
it's okay to have a disturbed spirit and
he always says when in doubt don't
so if a deal feels funny if i'm working
on a business deal
or a client and it feels funny
there's a reason it feels funny there's
something really going
on there you know and that's not that is
not to be discounted
um and so that that concerns me about
your situation
uh the second thing is there's a book
that my friend henry cloud did
called necessary endings when do you end
a relationship of any kind when you end
a relationship where you
like you say i'm going to quit a job or
i'm going to do a breakup
or i'm going to end a marriage or i'm
going to
end this friendship when do you end a
relationship
it is when you lose hope that the thing
of concern is
never going to get any better and the
the the character qualities that you've
lack of character that you've outlined
falls in that category and so
when in doubt don't and then the last
thing that popped into my head was this
ask yourself because you're wise beyond
your ears
15 20 years from now you're a teenager
girl
your teenage daughter is sitting in
front of you
and she asks you this exact question
what are you going to tell her about
this boyfriend
hmm and that one
that may end it for him no i mean
because that
he may be done when you ask me i mean
that pulls yourself out of the middle of
it
and now you're looking and talking to
someone you love in other words
does the 35 year old you yeah have
respect for the 27
26 year old you wow uh when you look
back and you go
whoo dodged a bullet on that one or hey
i'm glad i didn't overreact to a couple
of little things that's right that's a
good one of the two ways
oh that's a great perspective and just
back up from it a little bit and
so those are three things that i use i
look for that kind of a thing
and say you know long term
am i going to be glad i did this right
because if you back off and say long
term is this a good investment
long term am i glad that
when i'm 75 years old i mean uh we're if
we're negotiating severance with
somebody that we've let go here
right and a few dollars makes it
better that the pain of someone leaving
the building
i'm never gonna regret those few dollars
on my bed on my deathbed when i'm 78
right that's great uh and and i would
regret that a
relationship was ruined that didn't need
to be rude right wow
long-term perspective good perspective
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today here on the dave ramsey show
got a special treat for me and i hope
and i think for all of you as well
i've got my friend clark howard on the
line
hey clark how are you brother it's so
great to join you how are you doing
today
man i am great for those of you across
america that
uh have been living in a cave somewhere
you don't know things but if you do know
things you know clark howard is a big
deal in talk radio and has been
for several decades uh he and i have
been in the same space the money space
and the consumer advocate space he spend
spends a lot of his time on the air
uh talking about how originally talking
about how to get a good deal on like an
airline ticket he still does some of
that
uh and it has had several number one
best-selling books he's in the national
radio hall of fame uh our paths have
intersected many times i've got
huge respect for this guy and uh
we he has just made the decision to
retire from radio
he's going to continue to teach and
continue to have the clark howard show
on podcast
and uh and it's the work he does on his
websites and everything but we just
wanted to have him on and honor
my friend because he's done so much for
so many decades for so many people
using the power of radio to help them
clark thank you brother
well thank you and you and i were
inducted in the hall of fame on the same
night like or was it six years ago
something like that
yeah that's exactly right that's true
yeah irony of ironys because you and i
really we're i think we're probably the
uh by far the two largest names in radio
in the money space or the consumer space
i guess
there were a couple of other people on
radio back in the day doing this stuff
when we were there but i think they've
moved uh moved on to retirement many
years ago
and i think you and i i could be wrong
about this but i think you and i are the
only two people
in syndicated radio just about in the
history of syndicated radio
that own and operate our own shows
rather than working for the man
you know what that's true uh that would
be true uh let's say of size
there's a few of them do it that have
two shows or are two or three stations
but you had a pretty substantial network
and we do too
and yeah that's exactly right and you
would resisted that
um so i stumbled across your retirement
because
we picked up like 10 or 15 of your old
stations
when you when you wow congratulations
thank you
yeah it was a natural fit and i was
complimented that those stations
thought that you know that i could you
know that that audience of yours would
accept me
uh as well as anything else or better
than anything else out there and so
uh that added to our network so it's
good they didn't none of those stations
got handed off to the man
[Laughter]
well you are so much more energetic than
i am that
i reached a point where i'm working so
much
and our websites you know because
digital is
where the growth is it was absorbing so
much of my time that i was getting to a
point where i was
exhausted all the time and so something
had to give
and what gave for me what had to go away
was
radio you know it just weren't enough
hours in the day for me and so
the podcast and the websites that's
where it's at for me now
so when someone uh if they haven't for
some reason listen to the clark coward
show
and they tune it up on a podcast right
now what are they going to hear what are
you covering how are they
i know but i'm giving you an underhand
pitch here tell them what your podcast
is about
so what i very heavily concentrate on is
something i heard in one of your spots a
minute ago
it's about how to get your spending
under control
how do you get your life where you need
it to be where you're
living consistently every pay period
on less than what you make and there are
so many things we do now we have so many
decisions we have to make
if we get overwhelmed and we end up
spending money on things and
then the bills become automatic where
they're debiting our checking account or
whatever every month
and so i really try to get people to
focus
on controlling those expenses
with the big ones you know housing and
cars how those can eat up too much of
your wallet
and then with the regular spending how
to get those things
under control where you don't just set
them and forget them
you pay attention to them so that you
have more money
left at the end of every pay period
and of course that's where we're
completely aligned
and uh you know why people that are fans
of clark howard are often fans of dave
ramsey and vice versa
now what you are light years better at
and always have been than i
than i have been is you really dig up
deals
and you keep a good list of them and
present them to your audience i mean
you've got that clarkdeals.com you can
just go to that website and find out a
list of your deals right
okay so this is the angel on one
shoulder devil on the other so here i am
talking about spend less spend less
spend less than that and say
wait a minute there's a great deal you
got to know about this deal
so you don't look at the deals until you
got the other part together but yes i
i love the bargains and i'd love for
people to know how to
know when something is a deal instead of
a pretend
just because somebody says some things
for sale how do you know it's
really a sale and not a non-sale sale
and so i want people to be as efficient
with their spending as they possibly can
so that they free up choices in their
lives
you know i want people to not feel like
they're having to work
because they're facing a mountain of
expense and bills and obligations i want
them to work
because they love what they do and then
i want them to have excess money
so they can put it to work in good ways
in the world so they
tithe or they give to organizations that
they care about that they
spend time serving others in whatever
way works best for them
so having money available
isn't with money being your god
no it's about living on less than what
you make
so that you can have the freedom to do
more things
that you enjoy and in service to others
and it works every time clark howard is
our guest this segment he is retired
from radio
but not from broadcasting you can still
hear the clark howard show on
podcast go to clark.com it's available
on all the platforms
be sure you continue to tune in and for
those of you that for some reason have
not tuned in prior to now i'll give it
my hearty endorsement and say be sure
you do that
he and i have been friends acquaintances
for a long long time we've been in the
same space here in radio
both trying to survive in a corporate
world that's kind of cut throat
and uh both of us have survived and we
have both prospered by
delivering good solid content to our
audience and helpful content to our
audiences and
just a good man he's also a huge
philanthropist he gives and gives and
gives and gives he lives
he walks the talk for sure if i remember
right did you and i not do a radiothon
at a cancer hospital there in atlanta we
did we did i i do fundraisers for
children's cancer centers in not just
atlanta but other places as well because
you know when i see a child
suffering from cancer it affects not
just that child but the whole
family and it just eats at my heart as a
father of three children
i remember touring that thing i remember
touring that hospital with you
meeting some of those kids some of those
kids that were going through that and
their parents and
oh you just go there with your stomach
and your throat it's amazing
it was an honor to get to work on that
with you so
i want i don't not just the money that
i'm able to raise i also want to raise
awareness i
want people to know the phenomenal
people who work as nurses and doctors
and
other people in hospitals who take on
one of the most difficult tasks
of all which is to get attached to a
child
and watching a child suffer and
i mean that is a very special kind of
human being
who chooses to work in a children's
cancer center and the great work they do
do you know the survival rate of
children's cancers now
is above 80 percent and if you go back
two generations ago
it was only 25 percent yeah they've
really really are beating it it's pretty
amazing
pretty amazing well clark thank you for
taking time to join us congratulations
on your
uh partial retirement here
thank you and continued success to you
and to the people who watch me on my
various tv affiliates around the country
i really am as ugly as i look on tv but
that's okay the information's beautiful
all right folks be sure to tune in to
clark howard the clark howard show
anywhere you listen to podcasts you'll
be glad you did congratulations my
friend thank you for taking time to come
on
sure and continued success to you too
dave god bless
all right this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
do
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five brittany's in amarillo
texas hi brittany welcome to the dave
ramsey
hi dave it's such an honor to speak with
you i loved the reset last
night thank you glad you watched i
appreciate it
hogan did a great job didn't he i
can't even say how much i loved it it
was wonderful well thank you very much
i appreciate it how can we help today um
i'm hoping that
maybe you can help me decide if i should
delay going to school for one year to
save up money or if i should just
jump in a little bit of information
is i'm a 28 year old single mom and i
make forty thousand dollars a year
i'm in baby step three and i have four
thousand dollars saved
um and i've been cash flowing school
part-time right now with
grants and different things but i'm
pursuing a degree or a career
in dental hygiene which is a full-time
program
and the cost is in increases once i get
into the program so i'm looking at going
this fall
for that but i don't know if i should
wait and save up
a bunch of money because i'll have to be
working part-time
or if i should just go and try to cash
flow and work
like crazy while i'm in school okay uh
can you cash flow the school
and your life if you work like crazy and
go this fall
um and have a relationship with my
daughter maybe
i don't i don't think i'm not sure how
long is the school
it's two full years um how old is your
daughter
she's three
and i'll have it's the initial cost is
going to be
like 11 000 at the beginning of the
first semester
but it goes down after that because i
have to buy you know a
thousand dollar kit and things like that
so that's why the initial cost is going
to be
more than what it will cost for the rest
of the program okay so your concern is
the only way you can cash flow it is a
lot of hours of
work in addition to going
yes and i'll have to quit my current job
because the program but if you wait if
you wait a year
what happens what changes you're going
to have just a pile of cash you could
live on and you wouldn't have to be gone
so much working
yes i'm just scared that i'll lose some
momentum because i've been going and
i've been believing in myself enough to
get through
i'm just scared that i'll quit i don't
think you're gonna quit
no you sound motivated you sound very
very focused
on not only doing something for yourself
brittany but also for your daughter
i can hear it in your voice uh the
passion
do you have a support network around you
to help you with your daughter
yes i do okay a great one that's good
my parents are here and i have a really
supportive boyfriend that believes in my
dreams as well
okay so you're going to quit your
full-time job and you're going to
dental hygienist in the fall and you're
going to work a part-time job
to pay bills while you're going to
school
right yes doing what and what are the
hours
um i don't know
i assume i've i've had i've
been working retail somewhere like
yeah just somewhere working nights and
weekends or being a waitress or
something
yeah okay i think if you solve
that part of the equation and have more
detail
it could give you peace uh let me give
you an example
okay let's pretend that it was neither
one of the things you mentioned
but that the new part-time job was
something where
you made better money than those two
things and
i'm making this up in my head but also
you had control over your time
maybe it was a little bit of a small
business idea maybe you were
what do you do now i'm an administrative
assistant for
an accounting firm perfect let's pretend
that you were a
uh an off-site a and let's let's open
a a business called administrative call
called virtual administrative assistant
and you are going
to become an administrative assistant
for three different
small businesses that cannot afford a
full-time one
and you're a part-time for all three of
them but
it does not require you be answering the
phone during a certain time of the day
it just requires that you get
administrative assistant work
done which by the way you could do after
the three-year-old went to bed
okay and you'd make more than you will
and the dadgum reaper detail yeah
yeah i'm just making this up
but but what my point is is if you had
something like that
mapped out that you believed was real
and you start working towards
that i think a lot of your worry and
stress about abandoning your
child which is where the tears are
coming from is going to go away
yeah but if you have to work 40 hours a
week at retail just to barely scrape by
because you're not making
any money and your schedule is at their
beck and call they own you
then you are going to have a real stress
point with the baby right
right oh yeah and so let's just take
that off the table
either design something where you
control your time
and you make more money as your work
through
gig or you wait a year
okay because you're not going quite yet
brittany what baby step are you on right
now
i'm on baby start three and i have four
thousand dollars
okay okay you are on three okay i don't
think i
even if you delay it a year i don't
think you're gonna give up i really
don't i think
you know i what i would ask you to do
though is to really search your heart
and see
is the dental hygienist is that the
thing you're absolutely passionate about
yeah because you're going to be making
too many sacrifices for something that's
a maybe
so i think in that period of time you
can be as my grandmother would say
prayerful and careful to get certain
about what it is you want to do
and then begin to make the sacrifices
necessary so you can get there
let me tell you what i know about um
people in your situation i've worked
with single moms
for 30 years uh and they
uh they never think
not never but they work so hard there
are so many jobs just to try to get by
and they never think they're doing as
good a job as they are
and lady you're a warrior
and you don't even know it and you're
doing so much
better as a mom and as a woman
than you think you are because you've
you've been you've just been
a raw nerve for so long yeah that you
forget
how good you are and i man i tell you
and the other thing i got is i got a
whole building full of millennials and a
whole bunch of them were raised by
single moms and they all
stand up and salute to their warrior mom
including chris hogan yeah without a
shadow of a doubt you know it's one of
those things where
let me be the first to tell you britney
if you hadn't heard it
you're doing a good job amen you are
doing a good job
and keep being that role model for your
daughter because i'm going to tell you
what the what you deposit in that little
girl right now
are the things that she'll begin to
amplify and replay in her head and in
her heart
and that's the stuff that she'll begin
to believe about herself
and more importantly about the mom that
raised her so keep up the good work
keep your priorities in order and uh
keep people around you that believe in
you
and and and and remove those that don't
i hadn't thought about it but you and
christy wright
hmm yeah both warrior both are raised by
warrior women yep
without a doubt i mean uh christie's mom
running a bakery
yep and your mom raising two boys boys
working as a nurse
yeah no it's just uh i mean
it it is it's a feat and uh
and it goes unsung and it's not anything
you sign anybody up for
no i don't think it's not it's not the
way to go it's not like something to
aspire to
but but when you're there the the way
those ladies rise
to those occasions and fight their way
through that's exactly right
pretty stinking amazing very well done
you're going to be okay either way
i think if you design a better
job that pays more and you control your
time more like
something like i outline you're going to
get a lot more peace and you're going to
go on and go in the fall
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
picture your life with no credit card
debt no medical
debt no student loans
no car payments
can you even breathe that in how much
better would you feel after 2020 most
america most of america feels the same
way you do right now stressed and out of
control but this year can be different
it is time for you to take control of
your money
to insulate yourself from all the crap
going on out there
and the best way to do that is the
ramsay plus
money reset it's our challenge for
anyone who starts ramsey plus this year
how much progress can you make on your
money
if you went all in for 90 days
game on baby for 90 days all
in to paying off your debt fast and
finally saving for emergencies
with ramsey plus we're going to show you
ways to get
daily small wins with your money
and even some really big ones but when
you add them all together it's big
and you're going to be making progress
maybe for the first time in your life
on this money stuff we're going to help
you turn those wins into lifelong habits
this year you can just decide
to reset your money you can go all in
for 90 days and take control of your
money
make today day one and start ramsey plus
for free daveramsey.com
reset check it out daveramsey.com
reset and all of that of course is off
the reset event that we did last night
with chris hogan
craig groeschel rachel cruz and you can
still watch that it'll be up for a few
more hours
it was live last night 240 000 people
registered to watch it last night
it was the number two thing on youtube
in the world
that's mind-boggling i mean that is
absolutely fantastic
that you have that many people plugging
and getting this kind of information
to kick off this year the right way and
what we're not going to do is sit around
and wait on someone to save the day
as i've been telling people for years
let's get your own cape and when you
have a system that can help you like
ramsey plus
that is part of the process and there's
a cape
shortage in washington d.c
yeah here i'll give you six hundred
dollars
did that change your life if six hundred
dollars change your life let me help you
with this
your life sucks it didn't change your
life
even if you're unemployed you're having
trouble making ends meet and you're
struggling 600
doesn't check i mean all it does is just
give you a half a second of breathing
room and you're right back in the soup
and then they walk around strutting
around up there acting like they did
something
they didn't do anything except run this
nation further into debt
unbelievable unbelievable all for the
political aspect of i did something for
you so you need me
we don't need you of either party
we don't need you we don't have to have
you
so you got to get yourself in that kind
of position where that kind of attitude
is possible
if you're sitting around waiting on the
government to fix your life your life is
always going to suck
eli is with us in chicago hi eli welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you and chris doing
great man how can we help
man you know what i hope you guys have
more than a minute to talk because i got
a bone to pick with you too
i'm in a mess because i i followed your
baby steps like you said i was able to
buy my house
cash and then uh i sold
some of my real estate properties and i
have five hundred thousand dollars now
in cash and i don't know what to do with
it and this is all you you and chris
fault
yeah i hate it when this happens
eli i apologize buddy i apologize
i and by the way right off the bat i
want to say i watched your
show last night it was phenomenal chris
i love when you pick on your kids
yes thank you thank you thank you all
right so
do you have any rentals left do you have
any debt left at all
so so no i'm 37 years old and
i'm going to get a pension with the city
i work with the city here in chicago
like i said my house is worth about four
hundred thousand i paid it off uh in
cash
um i have five hundred thousand dollars
i'm trying to figure out if i'm why did
you sell the rent behind
so so in chicago i just i'm i'm so busy
with my job
my dad uh passed away recently so i've
been helping my mom out a lot so i
didn't want to overwhelm myself
so so i just so i have to so i saved up
all that
you know cash that i had bought a house
for my wife and i and then
anything i had over with their real
estate like i have it sitting but
i don't have anything uh saved for
retirement those were supposed to be my
retirement the building
so now i'm trying to see if i'm am i
ahead or at 37 years old or american a
little bit because i won't
you're you're almost you either are or
you're almost a millionaire yes
so okay so you're ahead you're a 37 year
old everyday millionaire
okay so the question is this you don't
want to buy more real estate because
it's too much hassle because you have so
many things going on right
is that right okay then i only do two
things with money eli
and so i and i don't ever reckon i don't
tell people to do stuff i'm not willing
to do
so i don't get fancy with it one of the
things i discovered when i first started
talking to rich people after i went
broke 30 years ago
was the stuff they do is think they put
money in things they understand
and they are not concerned about you
being impressed with their
sophistication
they put money in stuff they know
something about
that's right and i don't put and they're
most of their you know most these guys
that have
anywhere from uh uh one million to a 20
million dollar net worth
they are not fancy no with their
investing
it's very pretty straightforward and we
found that again
when we surveyed all these millionaires
in the one to five million dollar range
in particular
that's right so what i'm gonna tell you
is mutual funds since you don't wanna do
real estate i only do mutual funds in
real estate that's all i do
and so if i woke up and i was in your
shoes and right now i didn't want to
screw with real estate i just need to
get some money working for me yep
i'd put it in mutual funds across the
four types we talk about without a doubt
and eli i'm proud of you for making the
sacrifice
to be able to free you up to be able to
help your mom i'm sorry to hear about
your dad passing
yeah but you're right when you get when
you make a priorities you make decisions
you make sacrifices to match them
and that's what you've done and so my
friend i'm going to tell you something
don't overthink this
get connected with the smart vista pro
at 37 years old you are an everyday
millionaire
let's grow this money be intentional
about what you're doing but here's the
thing you're going to have to do
here's the word that's going to be the
the difference between if you become
a multi-millionaire or not and that is
playing defense
you've got to be smart and go cash only
and if you want a truck save up and buy
a truck you want a boat
well don't buy a boat but just be smart
be intentional
uh but don't don't don't go backward for
debt for any reason
at all and you're going to be on a great
path see if you take 500 and it's
invested in mutual funds
and they make 10 to 12 it's roughly
gonna double every seven years
you're 37 at 44 it'll be a million
yeah at 51 it'll be 2 million
at 58 it'll be 4 million
i think you're gonna be okay he's going
to be okay if that's all you do
that's what i mean by not fancy right
you know you're not constantly screwing
with it you're not going oh it's out
it's out of sync oh there's a problem if
you just put it in there
and set it and forget it leave it alone
look at it you watch it obviously but
i'm saying you don't have to constantly
be
like every day fretting over where where
this mutual fund is and all that get it
up online
if it does what the if it does what the
market has done
over its history right that's roughly
what's going to happen is every seven
years or so it's going to double
and that's if you don't add anything to
it right and if you don't take anything
out that's right and that's what i was
saying about not doing stupid and
staying allergic to debt
uh because the thing we know about debt
is that it's needy and greedy
right it's needy and angry he's away
from that he's on him
yeah just and that you know when that
happens what i was addressing earlier
for folks is
there's something there's this allure
that if it's not
complicated or uber sophisticated it
must not be good
yeah like like we think the rich really
do know secrets we don't know or
something
and they really don't all they did was
what you already know they just did it a
lot it's boring
and they do it consistently that
consistency yeah craig was talking about
consistency last night yeah oh he did
uh listen if you've not watched the
reset talk get over there
and watch it before they pull it dave
told the story of the pigs you got to
hear it
and craig shell did a great job as well
man well and then there's hogan and
rachel cruz i mean it was all-star
lineup yeah love it love it that puts us
out with the dave ramsey showing the
books thanks to james childs our
producer
madison filling in for kelly today this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five chris hogan ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host today you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
again triple eight eight two five
five two two five drew is in gilbert
arizona hi drew welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave chris it's a pleasure to talk
with you both and
appreciate the uh reset last night and
you guys did um
really appreciate it all you guys do
thank you sir
so we've been following you guys for
quite a few years and
our our kids are a product of your of uh
your teachings basically and your
principles um
so we've got five kids and i told my
oldest son
um when he was in junior high that i
wasn't going to be able to pay for five
kids to go to college
so he started pushing a lawnmower
started doing the artwork
doing things to save prepare for college
and he did and so he started to grow
started making money and he's a natural
saver he's an entrepreneur so he's a
freshman in college now
he's saved for he got all of college
saved
paid for um basically in the savings
account
and now he's just making more money he's
he's got basically six figures that are
coming in and
trying to help him understand what to do
what's next
um how do i advise you know with
um and help him plan getting through
college
and then this this financial blessing
that it's been it's a tribute to his
hard work and dedication
wow what to do with that what a great
kid yes
a proud dad too and you ought to be well
done
well done well i mean i am okay with
people
not investing except into their
education into themselves while they're
in school
even if that means there's a pretty good
sized pile of money when they come out
because when you come out of school and
then you're full time into the career
whatever that is and it sounds like this
guy's going to be an entrepreneur
having an extra 100 000 laying there to
start your life is never bad
yeah because i assume there's one thing
he's getting interested in his
finance right so the markets i wouldn't
i wouldn't screw around with anything
too complicated if you want to park it
in something like a
uh you know uh an index fund
or something like that in s p 500 chris
what do you think yeah i would just
again drew i'm gonna help him to be very
aware
his most important investment is in
himself right now and taking care of
college
so he could have an interest in it but i
i would not put him in that game just
yet
um you know you might take him and go
sit down with the smart vista pro
start to look at those funds and talk
about investing some
uh to allow him to have an interaction
and to gain confidence
but in terms of i'm gonna start my
wealth building no
process i'm going to start my retirement
process
you can it's okay to but
the most important goal is to make sure
he graduates with no debt and he
graduates yeah i agree and
i think you going in with him drew he
can have that conversation learn
uh you can talk with him and i i don't
see a problem fanning the flame of
knowledge for him
but as far as doing it i wouldn't get
too tactical right now but he's done an
amazing job
wow and be sure to celebrate him as that
dad regularly yes so he knows it
amen anthony is in trenton new jersey hi
anthony how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve how can we help
all right so i'm a 23 year old
i live in new jersey i have a
2011 chevy cruze it's worth about two or
three thousand dollars
i also have a 2003 nissan 350z
and i drive the chevy cruze the 350z
which is kind of like a
i got it for cheap i just fixed it up
and uh i'm trying to sell it right now
i have an apartment the rent is
about 1200 a month but i uh split it
with my girlfriend
and i pay 900 she pays the rest
um i guess my question is i'm looking to
buy a new car
so what i have is kind of giving me
problems and stuff
so i'm looking to see maybe getting like
a toyota tacoma or something like that
um but the only issue is the car is
about fifteen thousand dollars and i
have eighteen thousand saved right now
and i'm just trying to see what you
think if you think i should
pull the trigger on something that
expensive or i should what do you make
uh fifty five thousand uh gross pay okay
well a rule of thumb i use is not on
things that have motors and or wheels
added together
that equal more than half your annual
income because they all go down in value
it doesn't sound like you're going to
violate that i'm a little confused as to
why you have two cars
um well the so sometimes like i buy cars
that are like
i used to work on cars so i know what
they're too about them
the nissan was just a really good deal
and
so i just picked it up fixed some issues
with it and i was planning on selling it
oh
it just hasn't sold yet oh okay it's
just sitting in my driveway okay and so
you'd sell the you'd sell the chevy
cruze and your daily driver would be the
the tacoma well hold on a minute anthony
if you said you work on cars why can't
you fix the one you drive
i can but the thing is the work that it
needs it
costs about you know it'd probably be
around two thousand dollars
that's all that's thank you cars okay
yeah i mean you got the money you don't
want to be below your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and
you're getting pretty close on that
because you only got 18 and you're
talking about spending 15 right
right yeah that was the thing yeah i
don't want to get below whatever three
months of your expenses are you don't
want to get below that in the account
after you buy that
ticket and we sell the chevy we get rid
of the nissan z
and then use some of the money out of
savings and get a new to him car
yeah that's what he's saying yeah but if
you may not get into the 18 years you
may not need the 15k out of pocket
because you got the
proceeds from the other two cars other
two cars coming yeah that may make up
the difference in the emergency fund
because the 3k
left in that emergency fund sounds
shallow yeah it does dave especially
living in jersey
i mean that's that's then so you know
let's just make sure you don't leave
yourself vulnerable because of a stupid
car
that's what it comes down to so it might
be a 12 000 car
you know that might be what you're after
i don't know but it's somewhere in there
and
you're not over half your annual income
invested in things with wheels and
motors so you're cool there you're
paying cash so you're cool there
so overall the deal is good just don't
ever get below your three to six months
of expenses and emergencies
because you're inviting trouble that's
right and it's like sending out a ticket
it is and even if you've got to pick up
gigs on the weekend of fixing other
people's cars
that's a natural side hustle for you you
love cars
you have the skill and talent to be able
to work on them so again thinking
outside the box
and you hold off two or three more
months and then maybe you can go get
that other
15 000. yeah yeah exactly right so
sacrifice so you got to make sure you
have a plan for that
we live in a car culture and i love cars
i'm a car
junkie um so i kind of enjoy
the whole process of messing around with
them and i enjoy having a nice one and
all that kind of stuff not because i
care what somebody else thinks i just
like driving them
yeah and uh but the thing is they go
down in value so fast
and it is the largest thing that
everyone buys
that goes down in value it goes the
wrong way
so you've just got to limit the damage
that it does to your finances and that's
why we say no more than half your annual
income tied up in it
even if you're paying cash and you drive
really fast too
well there's that this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five paying off debt is of
course smart
saving and investing is of course smart
but there is a key to winning with money
that's often forgotten and that's
protecting your family
from emergencies there are 10 kinds of
insurance coverage that are good
there's a lot of gimmicks in that world
but you might need
all of these 10 kinds depending on your
life stage and we built a tool to show
you what coverage you need to add
dropper adjust takes only five minutes
it's the coverage checkup tool get your
phone out and it's free text
the word checkup to 33789
text checkup two three three seven
eight nine our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure you pick
the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping
new promos all the time use the promo
code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
all right today's question comes from
michael in california he says i'm
currently saving
15 of my income into my roth 401k plan
through my employer
the 401k plans portfolio is based on my
year of retirement
i'm 38 years old and make around 140 000
a year
i was wondering if you recommend
sticking with
what was pre-arranged for me and my
works 401k
portfolio spread the money out into my
own into the four different categories
of mutual funds i've heard you all talk
about on your show
or is that not an option with work
sponsored roth
40401 case well i mean
looking at this michael what it sounds
like is they've got you in a target date
fund
and a target date fund is simply this
it's just age-based
has nothing to do with your progress or
future it's just making an assumption
so i'm definitely going to recommend
that you utilize the four types of
mutual funds that we talk about
yeah you'll get a better rate to return
these uh
i i don't believe in the pre-packaged
portfolios
if you can avoid them at all if there's
a way to avoid them and it depends on
how your 401k
servicer has structured the thing but um
yeah i don't want anything that's
pre-arranged for me in my 401k
i want you to decide what mutual funds
your money's going into
i want you to make the decision i want
you
to be in control of this the
pre-arranged part scares the crud out of
me so i'm with chris and we recommend
and i personally don't do prearranged
we don't even offer pre-arranged
portfolios in in my 401k for our
thousand team members here
we don't even offer it we just put the
mutual fund options up there we expect
you to learn
about them and choose for yourself like
a grown-up yeah
because it's amazing dave those funds
automatically assume that you gear down
and take
absolutely no risk or i also
not get any growth after a certain age
which is ridiculous
so again you want to be in control work
with a smart investor pro
and invest in things that are going to
bring you a rate of return
nick is in atlanta hi nick welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave how you guys doing great man how
can we help
um so right now i am in a situation
where
um i'm getting married in july for
blessed uh for my future fiance
yay and uh yep super super
excited for it it's awesome so um
she's great and we're we're really
excited for our future and i just have
to say
uh you guys and your program is
something that i i love and it
gravitates
for me so well i love the the grime
mentality and long haul and
uh so right now we're on baby steps too
we're just paying off our debt
uh and we talked about attacking it
really between the three
between two of us it's just my car my
student loans
her car and i just wanted to get your
your opinion
on if you think financially we're in a
good spot and we're attacking this the
right way
okay so how much debt do you have
uh so my student loans is 6500
which i plan on having done by the time
july comes through
i'll have my car on my car which is
sixteen thousand
and her car which is right now at eight
thousand
okay and what do you make uh
combine 90. well you're not combined yet
what do you make
uh 54. what's she well then she makes 46
right
or 36. yes okay yeah all right
um okay but you don't pay on each
other's dad
yeah and it sounds like when you get
married you're gonna have two car
payments with a 90 000
income and that's going to be your first
order of business just to knock those
out
do either one of you have big money in
savings
uh yes right now i've got 45 000 saved
okay how much does she have saved
uh 15. and how much you all planning to
spend on this wedding
uh it's gonna be about 15 but uh we're
getting some help from our
parents okay how much are you planning
on spending on the wedding how much is
your
fiance going to spend not the parents
uh it's going to be about 5 000. each
out of pocket you
and her yes okay so you have 45 you're
going to spend five on a wedding
she has 15 she's going to spend five on
the wedding mm-hmm
did i get that right mm-hmm okay
the rest of it other than a thousand
dollars both of you are going to ride
towards your debt today
she's going to put 10 on her car and
you're going to pay off your debt today
wait a minute that is that doesn't sound
real convincing
no it's i i want to do it i i i guess
the scary thing of of bringing that down
to the
baby step one but well you're not you
yeah
you won't buddy you only got twenty two
thousand dollars in debt
right right no i know yeah it's it's
i don't know so you're gonna have you're
gonna have fifteen thousand dollars
laying around
and she's gonna be at baby step one yep
and then when you get married you're
going to pay off her car
after you combine your accounts after
you get married nick you guys are going
to be ahead of the game now
what what you're having right now is
called cognitive
that that is your your brain is going i
hear dave and chris
but that's not what i was design i don't
this is new and you're right it is new
information
it is totally different way of thinking
because we want you to start that
marriage off without
having debt hanging on for 10 or 15
years buddy
it's gonna pave the way for you guys to
start to really save up a fully funded
emergency fund if you're unwilling to
pay off your car today nick you should
sell it
well hold on he just heard it dave he's
okay it's
new to him he can do it
nick you're going to do it i believe in
you
well if you're going to do the reason
that we teach what we teach nick is it's
the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth yeah
and so you keep your set your finances
separate prior to marriage
and baby step one's a thousand dollars
anything above that
goes on all of your debts in your case
you're gonna do all that and you're
still gonna 15 000 left over
and you need five thousand set aside for
the wedding she needs five thousand set
aside for the wedding already did that
and uh then you're going to continue to
build your baby step three
until july into your fully funded
emergency
fund and she's gonna uh continue to pay
down aggressively on that car between
now and july
and if there's any car debt left and
there probably will be with her
after you get home from the honeymoon
i'm gonna knock it out you're gonna
write a check and be done with it and
then you're 100
debt free by the way you're probably
gonna have five or ten thousand dollars
left over after all that happens
by july because you're a saver and you
make pretty good money look
you take what he was paying on the car
the student loan of what she was paying
on the car
start saving that towards your fully
funded emergency fund
man you're gonna be there so fast to
some police and a young couple starting
off the right way
yeah that's boy nick play this call back
play it listen to it with her gain
agreement pinky swear and started
writing checks yeah
yeah set the five aside for the wedding
i'm not messing up the web no no no
not messing up the wedding but you guys
have done a good job saving money and
you've done a lousy job managing your
money
and so now we got to decide now we got
to fix it that's right
it really is that's what it comes down
to so we
know from studying millionaires that the
shortest path to being a millionaire is
not keeping money in savings while you
have a car payment it's not on the list
of things that millionaires did though
it wasn't on the list of things they did
it's on the list middle-class people do
it all the time
but not millionaires so it's just what
do you you know
what do you want to do how do you want
to win with money this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
christians in dallas texas
hey christian how are you hey dave and
chris
thanks so much this is kurt taking the
time today sure how can we help great
um i just want to say i'm a new
westerner and i'm really blessed to be
able to get the opportunity to speak
today
well thank you too um so just a bit of
background uh
i'm currently a semester ahead and so i
would have been going into my senior
year right now in general
uh my parents and i decided that it
would probably be best for me to
take a leave of absence and you know
take a step back and
kind of pay my loans down a bit before
before going into my final year
i chose to study sports management uh
since i realized i probably couldn't
play professionally but i still wanted
to stay within sports
but i think it's going to be very
difficult for me to find a job in that
field coming out of college since
my major is so restrictive and my
question really is today that
should i since my courses will transfer
limit within the business school
should i change my major to a bachelor's
in business management and
can i give myself a broader range of
options in order to kind of guarantee a
job
coming out of coming out of college
nothing guarantees you a job coming out
of college but
you're right in that you've um
you know you've kind of painted yourself
into a corner in an industry right now
that is
that is dead as a hammer i mean sports
management obviously the stadiums and
the arenas are all empty
uh and so i and i assume they're coming
back but i assumed
they would never go down so what do i
know um
i mean last time last year in march we
were saying wow
well at least this will be over in time
for football and then it wasn't
so uh what do i know i don't know
anything you know so
uh uh but but i do know that you can do
sports management with a business
degree uh it's tougher to get into
business
when you have a sports management degree
because it is narrow
and they're not that much different it's
eight classes or something different
right
yeah it's it's not much yeah i mean so
you could have all of the
uh actually as electives you could pick
up all the sports sports management
sports management stuff you still have
those tools in your belt
um meanwhile i just have a degree in
marketing or a degree
in management or whatever uh none of
these things guarantee you a
job anyway right and then none of them
keep you from getting a job if you
walked into our place we don't do sports
management
if you had a sports management degree
one of our guys in our in leadership
here is interviewing you
they're gonna have sense enough to know
that that's basically a business degree
with five or six sports classes
yeah and so we're gonna know that you've
got basic knowledge
uh you know in those areas from your
academic studies so if we're
interviewing you
common sense i'll tell you that so i
mean if anybody is dumb enough to look
down
at a resume and say oh we're not going
to interview the guy because he's got a
sports management degree instead of a
business degree
yeah they got an issue then they're stu
too stupid to work for
really i agree christian how much
student loan debt do you have
as of now um i'm at about 51.
okay so i would have been i would be
adding 29 for my last year yeah we don't
add any so
tell me this what sport did you play
uh i grew up playing soccer okay and so
i got recruited to play
at richmond university um and so um
it's over in london and so they're not
really funding my my tuition and so it's
kind of
a gig where i go come over and play but
you know you gotta worry about
your you have to pay for it right okay
yeah all right
well i i like the mindset that you have
about shifting to business
uh i also i also like the mindset of you
kind of taking a step back here and
going okay let me attack this debt
gain some real world business experience
while you're doing it
that way you can cash flow that senior
year and i don't care if it takes you
five six seven years to get the degree
uh as long as you get too long well if
you if what i'm saying is if he
takes off a year or two to be able to
pay off short period of time you know
during this short period time you need
to pile up some cash pay cash for your
last year or last year
and make the make the major change i
would uh and while you're
doing the major change pick up the
sports management stuff that is the love
of your life as electives
and you've still got them as tools in
your belt but pay cash for your last
year
and i would make the move but uh for two
reasons one is it's a very narrow degree
two is uh uh
the sports management world is just it's
upside down right now and i don't know
what i don't know what's going to be
there
yeah i can't tell you i can't tell you
it's not going to be there i don't think
it's going to be destroyed permanently
the world is too much sports fans yeah
too many sports fans so something's
going to happen
christian before you go i'm going to ask
madison to get your information i'm
going to send you ken coleman's book
proximity principle
because this is something that will give
you some real world experience as you're
building your career
of getting around certain people
building relationships and starting that
right now
yep tequila is with us in atlanta hi
takiyah how are you
hi dave it is a pleasure to talk to you
today you too how can we help
um so quick question for you um i've
been debt free since 2016
thanks to you and your team um i'm
essentially looking for permission to
spend a pretty significant amount
on a vehicle um so i'm in baby steps
four and six
i have about 125 000 saved
and i'm considering buying a car that
will cost between 50 and 60 000
um so i'm trying to see if that makes
sense what do you make
182 182 000
yes and you have 125 saved
yes and you're in for you're in baby
steps four five six
yeah yes i would buy that car as long as
it's not brand new
awesome thank you so much what is the
car
um the bmw x5 oh sweet
yes nice car very nice so what one year
old two-year-old
i'm probably one-year-old yeah okay good
very good tequila how much do you owe on
your home
i'm 252 000
and i just started attacking my mortgage
actually this month and i'm
hoping to pay it off um by september of
2024
you're heavy in savings right now so
that savings needs to be on four five
and six
other than the car in the emergency fund
okay
okay yeah you're sitting a little heavy
on cash you don't need 125 000 in your
emergency fund
now we're gonna pull 60 out you probably
don't even need 60 in your emergency
fund do you
no i think um my six months is probably
about
really 20-25k realistically okay well
let's leave 30 in there for
just for comfort because you make you
make really good money
let's pull 60 out for the car and let's
put the rest of it on the house
thank you both i appreciate it you're
doing great wow
you were awfully affirmative on this car
why not that's a big dollar amount dave
well she's earned the right i mean she
makes 180 grand
and she had the cash i thought you'd
give a little pushback she had the cash
i mean well i mean she's not it's not
half her income
she's not buying that is true she's not
buying new it's not she's not
she's not a millionaire so she's not
buying new she didn't get the house paid
off yet
so uh but it's it's it fits i mean
it's just it's zeros yeah no you didn't
it's a lot i mean
if you make 60 000 a year you shouldn't
be doing that no i completely agree
maybe i'm just frugal maybe
okay come on to the next call i'm not i
was like a softball pitch to you i'm not
doing that
come on hit the button dave come on
let's get to the caller
nope uh-uh too late too late
maybe i'm just fruit okay come on hit
the button come on what's up
wow now we there's you ain't got time to
take a call it's almost like time to
commercial but
you've already walked into it yeah i did
oh
goodness gracious listen everybody we
had are you a spender are you a shaver
uh i am a spender i am i really am and
uh you know it's one of those
i had to really reel it in as i talked
about in the reset event last night with
my groceries
uh back in the day and just crazy i mean
it was really a growing moment i was
laughing my butt off
and i know a lot of you listeners out
there you've got a category in your
budget that gives you trouble
and as i talked about it i want you to
go watch the reset event because as you
begin to see it you realize i'm gonna
make a decision for myself and my future
and you start making these sacrifices
and it's okay to be uncomfortable
as long as you're being productive so
check it out you'll get a laugh
and you'll get some facts scooping up
some eggs scoop up eggs
i never scooped up eggs until i heard of
you this is great
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ecclesiastes 7
14 and the day of prosperity be joyful
and in the day of adversity consider
god has made the one as well
as the other so that man may not find
out anything
that will be after him robert louis
stevenson said to be
truly happy is a question of how we
begin
and not of how we end of what we want
and not of what we have
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five andrew is with us in
orlando hi andrew welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave and chris so excited to talk to
y'all thank you
sure how can we help so i'm 25 years old
i don't have any debt i graduated
college this past may
and i was able to live at home and do an
in-state school
and so i was able to save a lot during
those years
and right now i have about 3 500 in the
bank
and then i have a charles schwab account
that i just transferred about thirty
eight thousand dollars into
but it's not invested right now and so
i'm wondering
what y'all's thoughts are on what i
should should i do a lump
big sums of something into different
funds or
what's your idea and thoughts on that
now did you graduate yet
yes sir and i just started a new job
great
great and have you moved into your new
place
um well right now i'm actually still at
home
and i'm hoping i'm talking to a friend
of mine we had actually moved out
together but once cove had hit we moved
back in
to our house and so i'm looking with him
right now to move out
okay cool what do you do for a living
how much do you make
right now i make about 30 000 but that's
i'm working part-time
this new job i got i should be starting
full-time
in the next few weeks or the next month
or so
and then that should bring it up and
hopefully i'll get a pay raise in there
as well
where did the money in the charles swab
account come from
it came i had it just in my savings
account i had been
just saving for years and then i just
kind of transferred it over
wanting to kind of get started on some
stuff all right and how's your car
what kind of car do you have um it's
it's paid off it's a
toyota okay and i don't so i don't have
any debt right now
okay and you plan to have this vehicle
for what another five ten years
yes sir you know it's in really good
shape that's good
that is good well i like the fact that
you all are planning to get back out on
your own
you and a roommate um and so you know
with that in mind
beginning to look and giving yourself
some cushion if your car is stable
right and you're making 30 you're
getting ready to try to get to full time
you have some of that money you hold on
to for as part of your emergency fund
the rest of it i'm going to invest that
for the future buddy
yeah and or and or it's your first home
fund to either one whatever you want to
do with it
that's what i was thinking about too i
wasn't sure because i had originally
kept it in savings
but i didn't really have a purpose of
okay i'm saving up for this
and so i just started thinking it was
probably not super smart to just let it
sit there that's that's good yeah
i don't mind that at all i would invest
it either
into retirement accounts and roth iras
and so forth
uh and or i would put
aside from the emergency fund and or i
would just set aside invested in a
mutual fund for your first home purchase
and continue to add to it
and that's your down payment fund and so
now it's got a name it's got a purpose
and that's very smart for it to have a
purpose
that also tells you how to invest what
to invest it in
once you give it a name once you give it
a purpose shelby's in saint louis hi
shelby welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can i help
i have a question about life insurance
my parents bought a life insurance
policy when i was born
and i'm 26 years old i don't know i was
diagnosed with
childhood leukemia when i was 13. i'm 13
years cancer free now
yay but i'm facing the decision um
of keeping that policy upgrading that
policy or taking the money and running
and getting i know you guys preached her
life insurance but i'm just
not sure what to do since i have that
history of cancer
yeah well what you need to do is figure
out if you can get term get in touch
with zander insurance and see if 13
years from childhood is enough to
clear you to get term insurance if it is
then it's time to get a big girl policy
and let this whole thing go away
upgrading
i don't know what upgrading means
getting getting whole life
i shouldn't say upgrade i'm saying
updating um it's a
variable appreciable life policy that i
have now and they're trying to update me
to a
permanent life insurance policy that's a
downgrade actually no i wouldn't do that
i know i wouldn't do that the only
question is do you keep what you have
because you're uninsurable or do you get
term insurance and drop this crap
because you're able to get insurance
those are your two choices that's right
okay yeah and shelby so what you do is
reach out to xander go ahead and apply
and begin through the process they'll
walk you through it and guide you
and if for some reason it comes back
that you're uninsurable
you'll be able to work with one of our
insurance endorsed local providers to be
able to guide you
to find out what other special policies
are available
that are going to be a better overall
deal for you than this permanent life
yeah the life insurance world
jeff sander and i were talking about
this over the holidays we were together
um
you know for christmas party and stuff
and um
uh he was saying that it's amazing in
the last even
five years how the life insurance world
is now covering
things that they wouldn't cover before i
mean like back in the day when i started
if you just said cancer out loud you're
done
yeah you know or in her case that would
be you just you're done even though it's
13 years ago even though childhood
leukemia
even though the survival rate on
childhood to leukemia is very high
doesn't matter doesn't matter you're
done nowadays they look at it very
carefully
and they've been able to write policies
uh for people that have had diabetes or
people that have had a cancer or had a
heart attack scare
uh or something now if you're square in
the middle of it they're not going to
yeah it's going to be tough to get
coverage on that obviously
but um you know the number of years they
want to wait that you're cancer-free has
changed
they're just much more lenient on their
underwriting now because i think they've
got better data
yeah that they're working with in order
to in order to book those in
and um so guys let me just tell you
something
term life insurance if you haven't
priced it
you know unless you have an illness or
something where you're getting raided up
uh the prices are ridiculously low
it's just bla you know you what 13
a month will buy you if you're 30 years
old will blow your freaking mind
i mean it's unbelievable yeah and and
really here
if you've got dependents or people
counting on you this is not an option
uh you want to make sure that you've got
term coverage outside of your job
that policy with your job is not going
to provide you enough
it's not doing enough so we tell people
10 to 12 times your income
uh so if you're making 50 000 a year
you're looking at 500 to 600
000 in term uh but it's really how you
say you love your
your family it's how you say i love you
because you're going to provide them
money to be able to take care of things
after you're gone
finish funding college finish paying off
the house finish
whatever it is that they need to do so
please don't delay
uh and if you've had this through your
job it's not portable it's not going to
follow you
and i wouldn't delay because of this
coveted mess either no because covet is
going to affect life insurance policy
prices
i don't know exactly how yet right
because we don't know what the data is
the actual death rate on covet is not
high enough
to affect it but the illness and the uh
man it's
it's it's got that business spook that
business is a
numbers-driven statistics-driven
business and they don't like
uncertainty they don't like pandemics
and so they may jack policy rates up
soon
just in case that's right that's exactly
right and then bring them back down
later later you're right so
i if if you're if you haven't if you've
been dilly-dallying around about this
you're getting your dadgum term
insurance in place now yeah
all right that about puts this
particular hour in the books if you have
not seen
the reset event that was live last night
240 000 folks signed up to see it last
night
it was chris hogan dave ramsey rachel
cruz
and craig groeschel all four were on
their game including me
so check it out daveramsey.com reset
it'll be up for a day or so more
uh there'll be over a million people
watch it by the time it's over
and it's completely free james childs
good job in the booth madison thank you
for filling in for kelly good stuff
chris hogan thanks for hanging out
yes this is the dave ramsey show we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one
way to financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
so
you